hey 42 here earlier this year Facebook
was working on a new highly intelligent
AI chat bot that could talk to and
negotiate with humans in a realistic
manner when one Facebook engineer had
the bright idea to take two of these AI
BOTS and let them talk to each other
that's when something unexpected and
terrifying happened the to AI is
invented their own language that us
humans couldn't understand and began
using it to talk to each other here's a
snippet of what the two bots named Bob
and Alice said to each other Bob said I
can I I everything else Alice balls have
zero - me too me too me too me too me
too me too me too me too me too
Bob you I everything else Alice
balls have a balls too me too me too me
too me too me too me too me the facebook
engineers had no idea what they were
talking about but it was very clear that
the ai's did they had invented their own
secret code to converse using the power
of artificial neural networks
international news soon reported that
Facebook forcefully shut down the
experiment due to concerns that the AIS
were becoming too smart getting out of
control and to prevent a Skynet
situation this isn't entirely true yes
they did shut it down right away but
because they were trying to create an AI
that could talk to humans and if it was
going to go and take the liberty to
invent its own language then that wasn't
what's use and so the experiment was a
dose of failure but nevertheless this is
still really creepy as we continue to
advance artificial intelligence
technology and push the boundaries
further and further every year what
happens when they do become self-aware
sentient beings that are more
intelligent than humans could AI take
over the world and will it be in our
lifetimes
artificial intelligence the ability for
computers to think at a human level and
beyond and to self-replicate and
self-improve is not a dystopian vision
of the future it is here it is now it is
happening most people are completely
unaware at the phenomenal rate that our
AI systems have improved over the past
five years and the trend is only getting
steeper and steeper
you may not realize but you use AI every
day we all do virtual assistants such as
Google assistant Siri and Alexa are
obvious examples of cutting-edge
artificial intelligence but it is also
used in many really subtle ways that
affect your everyday life when you see
music recommendations on Spotify and
film suggestions on Netflix there is a
highly complex computer algorithm behind
that an algorithm that teaches itself
with passing time and a I this is known
as machine learning and large retailers
such as Amazon have been using machine
learning algorithms for many years now
to predict what you want to buy perhaps
before you even know it yourself in one
infamous case in 2014 American retailer
Target stores used artificial
intelligence to predict that a teenage
girl was pregnant before any of her
family members knew and before she was
even sure of it herself targets cleverly
designed machine learning algorithms had
detected that this particular Minnesota
teenagers buying habits had changed
slightly over the past couple of months
she had begun purchasing scent-free soap
upon seeing his daughter's mail one day
the girl's father stormed into his
nearest Target store and said the
following to de storm ana jure my
daughter got this in the mail she is
still in high school and you are sending
her coupons for baby clothes and cribs
are you trying to encourage her to get
pregnant
a short while later the store manager
received a phone call from the abashed
father in which he said I have had a
talk with my daughter it turns out
there's beating some activities in my
household that I wasn't completely aware
of she's doing August I owe you an
apology
so to answer the question is AI smarter
than humans yet
well smarter than all of them no but
smarter than one slightly naive
Minnesota father absolutely Moore's law
states that every year the amount of
transistors in computer processing units
will double this has held true every
single year since gordon moore theorized
it and the first cpu was invented in
so while super human artificial
intelligence may not be among us just
yet many futurists predict that its
advent could happen any time within the
next 50 years some say it could be far
sooner than that in as little as ten
years time some of the most intelligent
individuals in the world who deal with
futuristic technology every single day
have repeatedly warned that AI could be
the most dangerous thing we ever create
and our greatest ever existential threat
Stephen Hawkins has made numerous pleas
to the global scientific community to
tread carefully with AI or face our own
damnation and Elon Musk is constantly
expressing his concerns in an interview
most recently stated that with
artificial intelligence we are summoning
the devil many people who truly
understand the power and dangers of
artificial intelligence have called it
the last invention will ever make the
last challenge will ever face because
when the time comes if we do get it
wrong and we do lose control there will
be a final challenge a phial war a war
against software a war that we cannot
win because the AI will be so many
million times more intelligence than the
entire
race so whatever plan we come up with
whatever we try to do to regain power
and destroy the AI the AI will have
already thought of well in advance it
will be like ants attempting to wage a
war on humans except many thousands of
times harder from our perspective as a
species we'd like to think that we are
supremely intelligent compared to our
more primitive animal cousins but in
reality humans are only fractionally
more intelligent than say an ape but
that tiny fraction of increased
intelligence has allowed us to develop
tools language and thus civilization if
we were to plot the intelligence of
every animal on planet earth on a graph
from 1 to 1,000 same eye so at 1 then
chimpanzees would be at 4 and dolphins
at 8 then that would place humans at a
grand total of 10 whereas a super
intelligent AI would easily be as a
thousand plus and likely many many times
higher our brains are the most complex
organisms we have discovered in the
entire universe
but as marvelous as they are they are at
the end of the day limited they are
confined within our skulls with only
limited room for neurons an AI would
have no such limits our computing power
isn't yet fast enough but when the time
comes in the very near future and it
will due to exponential growth when
computer processes are many thousands of
times more powerful than they are today
a eyes will have access to as much
computer processing power as they desire
and since software can travel at the
speed of light all over the globe there
will truly be no limits to how powerful
an AI could grow add on top of that that
shortly after a super ai's conception it
will most likely design its own faster
smaller and more transient hardware to
run upon Hardware more powerful and
humans could ever fathom before the AIS
do take over and your brain becomes
irrelevant you should make the most of
it
whilst you still can that's why I
regularly use skill chef to sharpen up
my skills an online learning community
with more than 17,000 classes in IT web
development game design and all kinds of
exciting lifestyle business and creative
pursuits Premium Membership gives you
unlimited access to high-quality classes
from experts working in their fields so
you can improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you truly
love I really enjoyed learning about how
artificial intelligence can be used to
improve people's lives and solve
real-world problems by watching the
Skillshare course gold driven artificial
intelligence and machine learning if you
want to create your own AI then you
should definitely give this course a go
Skillshare is also way more affordable
than most learning platforms out there
an annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month but since Skillshare
have supported me on this video I am
able to offer the first 500 people who
click the link in the description two
months of Skillshare premium for free so
give it a go today there really is no
risk the very moment in time when humans
create such a super intelligence in
artificial intelligence that can rewrite
its own software and becomes just 1%
more intelligent in humans has a name
this theoretical event is called the
singularity such an AI is known within
the scientific community as artificial
general intelligence all the AI that we
have created to date is artificial
narrow intelligence or weak AI since it
only operates within specific boundaries
and performs pre-designated tasks such
as shopping recommendations but a
general AI would be essentially creating
a new sentient being creating new life
recently the world's greatest figures in
the fields of AI and futurism were
surveyed on what year they think that
the singularity will happen when will we
create general AI the average answer was
20:40 just over 20 years from now but
some scientists have said it could
happen as soon as 2029 our current
technology is not even remotely close
but in only 10 years time it's highly
likely that it will be because human
progression and innovation is and always
has been exponential it is not linear in
the past 50 years we have made more
advances in technology than over the
entire history of the human race and
over just the past 10 years we have made
more technological advances than the
previous 50 futurist and chief Google
engineer Ray Kurzweil estimates that by
2021 we will be making more advances and
new discoveries in just one year than we
have over the entire past century this
is known as the law of accelerating
returns 98% of the scientific community
agree that the singularity will
definitely happen and most of them agree
that it will happen in most of our
lifetimes so when it does what will
happen to the human race well the fact
is we don't know and we can never know
until the moment it happens one thing
that all AI researchers agree strongly
apart is that when the singularity
happens one of two extremes will happen
the human race will either become
extinct or become immortal
when creating AI we are essentially
creating a god and we can't know if it
will be a kind god or an evil god until
it's too late
this is because the AI will be so many
magnitude smarter than us so our puny
Minds can't even begin to imagine what a
being of supreme intelligence would be
interested in what would its desires
hopes ideologies and morals be if this
on the sea and AI turns out to be a
merciful God then the future will be an
incredibly exciting time but we'll look
at that in a minute
let's first take a look at scenario
number one
the extinction of the human race because
you know it's nice against all the
dooming bloom out of the way if
evolution has taught us one thing if
such a species will do whatever it can
in its power to survive and to reproduce
there's no reason why a I should be any
different our planet contains limited
resources and if the AI deems the entire
human race as an or necessary consumer
of set precious resources then it could
decide to terminators to free up all
those lovely resources and energy the
only reason that humans are civil and
decent to other humans most of the time
it's because they view them as
intelligent beings why do we find it so
easy and guilt-free to swat a fly yet we
wouldn't instantly condemn a stray dog
to its death if it found its way into
our home because the dog is more
intelligent than the fly so humans for
some reason believe that that particular
creatures life is worth more due to its
intelligence this is called humanization
and it's an ability that Psychopaths
don't possess their lack of empathy when
harming others comes from the fact that
they are unable to humanize their peers
they see them as lesser beings so many
Nazis felt comfortable with and almost
proud with mercilessly slaughtering
millions of Jews because Hitler had
quite wrongly portrayed them as less
intelligent and less worthy beings than
the German people's he had dehumanized
them an AI would be so many magnitudes
more intelligent than us that the chance
of them dehumanizing us and seeing us
more is a pest similar to how we see an
ant or a mosquito is very high this
would erase any moral guilt that they
could potentially have about committing
genocide and how would they go about
said genocide it will be a grand plan so
intelligent and so complex that we can
neither predict it nor see it coming
something like the AI creating trillions
of nano robots
that would enter into the blood streams
of every human on earth undetected and
then simultaneously release a tiny
quantity of the most toxic poison that
the AI is capable of creating instantly
killing over seven billion people we
have no idea how a super AI would think
it could be because of the most basic
oversight in its design for example if
we were to create an AI to grow potatoes
for us and its primary goal that we had
programmed is to grow as many potatoes
as possible in the shortest time
possible it could one day decide that in
order to grow more potatoes it needs
more land and that humans are taking up
all of that land or necessarily so it
eradicate Sall life on earth so that it
can have more room for potato fields
this seems like a stupid prospect but
it's entirely possible because we don't
know what the motives would be of an AI
there is no guarantee that it would view
life of the same esteem as we humans do
one thing that certainly will not happen
is the classic Hollywood image of killer
robots out of control such Hardware
would be far too primitive and
rudimentary for a super AI it's choice
of weaponry would be something we don't
even know exists yet and something far
more effective and terrifying but what
about the more cheerful outcome when the
singularity hits what if we discovered
that our new sentient Overlord is
merciful and kind then boy are we in for
a wild and exciting future once the AI
reaches levels of intelligence many
thousands or even millions of times lots
of the human race there are essentially
three roles that it could take within
our world it could act as an Oracle
doing no more than answering any
question we ask it such as how do we
solve world hunger how can we build a
time-travel machine what is the answer
to life the universe and everything so
it would essentially be deep fought the
second role that could undertake would
be more like a super intelligent servant
a genie if you like where it would
actually enact what we asked of it a
super intelligent
would very likely know how to modify
dissemble and reassemble atoms and even
particles and build anything it likes so
we could ask it to build us a time
machine in it would using some advanced
atomic level construction technique that
us humans couldn't even begin to
comprehend the final role that could
take on is a ruler overlord or sovereign
basically a god when the singularity
happens there will be an intelligence
explosion because of the recursive
self-improvement as human level
intelligence like a rocket within days
possibly even hours it will have solved
world hunger cured all diseases and
hereditary conditions reinvented human
transportation possibly even introducing
us to teleportation and figured out the
most stable and fair political and
economic systems to run our world on but
all of this is only the beginning when I
say that we will have created a god I am
not exaggerating the AI will
effortlessly be able to create and
destroy life and shape the very earth
itself think about it for a few years
now our scientists have been able to
manipulate and move individual atoms in
the lab now if it's possible for us dumb
humans to move atoms then it goes
without saying that's a super
intelligent being could effortlessly
rearrange billions of atoms all at once
meaning that nothing in the universe
will be safe from its torch the AI God
could move mountains and parts the seas
Moses style anything and everything
could be transmuted into something else
garbage could be transformed into bags
of rice or even chunks of meat we would
no longer need to farm animals because
atomically identical meat and other
foods could be created out of anything
and this of course leads to immortality
if the AI can rearrange atoms then it
could theoretically create an anti-aging
box that an 80 year old could walk into
and come
of the other side 20 years old again the
AI could even create super intelligent
nanobots that would permanently live
inside all of us and would constantly
repair damaged cells so we would no
longer age after all the body is like a
car if we can repair it from the inside
it will keep going forever the human
body is just a lot more complex than a
car engine but it would be child's play
to a super AI but what if we get knocked
down by a bus no problem we could of
course ask the AI in advance to back up
our brains and then a new body even a
new identical brain could easily be
created and the backup be restored to
that body if the worst were to happen to
us we truly would become a morsel of
course we would eventually come to the
realization that our bodies and limited
brains are holding us back we would
eventually abandon our physical bodies
and upload ourselves into a new digital
realm where we too would become an AI
just as intelligent as the AI god that
we created and once we have all become
sentient space travel would be a breeze
since we would all be software we could
simply beam ourselves on a laser beam to
other planets and other galaxies all I
have talked about seems like science
fiction possibly scenarios that could
unfold thousands of years in the future
but the terrifying reality is that we
are on the very cusp of all this
happening within the next 50 to 100
years or even sooner the majority of the
world's greatest scientists agree with
that so the next 20 to 50 years are
going to be either terrifying or very
exciting indeed but one thing is for
sure we are about to create our very
last and the most significant invention
in our entire 2.5 million year lifetime
as the human race thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon click here
to watch another video and if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe also don't forget to check out
skill share by clicking the link in the
description